what if I choose the wrong path so I got
a great question for my YouTube viewers
love you guys
game over who wrote in to say most
inspirational video yet better than the
belief videos haha but for real I love
your videos I wanted to ask you about
career path in decision I have a
crippling fear I might choose the wrong
path I have multiple ideas how do I know
which to try first this is a great
question and one that everybody goes to
everybody has fear and fear sucks
because fear holds you back
fear holds you in place fear keeps you
in a life that you're living right now
and if you want something greater if you
want something better for yourself
then you're gonna have to bust through
what is your comfort zone and that's
scary and that's gonna be fearful and
the advice isn't don't be afraid because
you're gonna be afraid it's to to be
afraid and do it anyways to know that
you're trying to do something bigger
than yourself you're trying to step
outside that comfort zone and go out
there something that's important and
meaningful for you and the way to reduce
the fear is to take smaller steps
the smaller the step is the less fear is
associated with it and by having a
confidence in courage to take that one
step you move another step and another
step and another step it kind of sounds
like you're an over planner and and I
and typically an over planner as well
and I have this challenge where I want
it to be perfect and I want to have it
all laid out and I'm gonna do this this
this this this and this and you have it
it looks great on paper but as soon as
you get out there and start doing all
your assumptions will be wrong it's
never gonna work out like it works out
on your paper and so the way to start is
to start you actually go you have three
things you want to be so you want to be
a professional gamer see you want to be
a bartender and see you want to be a
chef and you're not sure which of those
you want to do which is gonna be your
life's passion just go out and start
trying to do it stop reading papers and
watching videos and whatever you're
doing to plan and kind of make the
decision go out and try it because you
may try it for a day and realize wow
this is not for me I'm so glad I didn't
come
myself to doing this right now you may
try for a week and we try it for a month
you keep doing it as long as you love it
as soon as you stop loving what you're
doing you stop and you do something else
because you're not going to achieve
anything great you're not going to have
a major impact in this world by doing
something that you don't love and that's
the mistake most people make most people
they don't have a great life right they
work at a job that they hate and they're
living for the evenings and the weekends
I don't want that to be you and they get
stuck on this path that then they can't
swerve away from because it's too risky
or too scary so the best way to do it
especially now when you have these
opportunities they start on all three
paths and figure out which one is more
exciting for you start trying it take
whatever that first step is go get a job
working for somebody who's doing it just
start and see if you love it see if you
go there and you can't wait to go back
the next day or do you go and say wow
that wasn't that great and that's that's
the greatest education you can get
because it helped you find what you're
not supposed to do and lean you to
another path don't make it this big
all-important decision because the
career you end up with may not even be
one of the three or four that you start
with but what you have to do is have the
courage to take one small step towards
just testing it and it doesn't have to
go in thinking this has to be the
greatest day of my life you're just
testing it and seeing if you like it and
if you like it you go back and do it
again and again and again and if you
like gross to love gross the passion you
found your path if you like gross - okay
gross to boredom gross to hatred then
you gotta move on and do something else
so have the courage to get started and
listen to your heart until you find the
right path for you believe so those you
watching you like the video you can
support me by clicking on the link in
the description leave a comment below
let me know what you think and click on
my face subscribe to the channel thank
you so much I'll see you soon